the main thing with the classics is it's
all one-day racing and there's quite a
few days of trading in between and it's
getting the balance of training and
recovery right the classics are
incredibly exciting races the action
comes thick and fast in a classic Swiss
I just find them more more fun to race
more entertaining bit less predictable
I'd say the biggest difference between
the classics on the ground - is the
duration of the particular if so many of
them are over six hours in duration but
also the intensity and the intensity can
go up and down at various stages and
because of that then really it's all
about carbohydrate and we have to really
make sure that we adhere to best
practice nutrition and for us 90 grams
an hour when on the bike is an absolute
must I work really closely with James
it's like a triangle really with the
rider James and myself so you know James
has direct contact with the riders all
the nutrition that they're taking in on
the race off the race through that
classics period and all the monitoring
through that time and certainly with
James's input and his attention to
detail and the way in which he uses
science in sport products to sort of
help us monitor and maintain weight has
been really good
physically you've got to be one of the
best and you got to ride a smart race
you've got to know when to be in the
front and where not to be
looks a great writer for us in the
classics he's really in the engine room
though he does a great job and because
Luke's role really is to generate at
that high power output for a sustained
period of time then we have to make sure
that he really adheres to the basic
principles of carbohydrate fueling and
that all comes back to 90 grams per hour
but really it's about 20 minute feet but
of course sometimes the risk can be
quite unpredictable and if that happens
and you miss a particular feed then we
try and double up with the next feed so
that we always still come back to that
60 to 90 grams per hour and looks really
great at that axilla
[Music]
it's like a fight you just got to keep
going and going and I watch it heard she
got a crack on and there's times where
you think I don't want my limit here but
he's mentally everyone else is on their
limit and he's got to put it to one side
and just crap off personally I love the
classics it's just the excitement on the
day I think the crowd you know the the
atmosphere I can enjoy that you know and
I enjoy the challenge that we've had
with the these young British lads you
know that we've grown up with these guys
they've grown up in our team and you
know if they can win one of these big
classics it'd be a great story yeah
you